i was diagnosed with juvenile rheumatoid  arthritis in 37 joints when i was seven  i was put on two immune suppressants in  an anti-inflammatory medication  um the immune suppressants i injected so  very serious immune suppressants when i  was in grade six i was diagnosed with  major depressive disorder or possibly  bipolar type two depending on the  physician and i was put on ssris  um grade eight i started to get  chronically fatigued so i was medicated  with adderall when i was 21 for  idiopathic hypersomnia so i used  adderall just to stay awake when i was  17 i had my hip and ankle replaced from  the arthritis that wasn't kept in check  properly with the immune suppressants  yeah that's about it i was also  diagnosed with lyme disease eventually  and  i think that's all of them